pena bonjour à tous merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition
deux parlements et dos en compagnie
aujourd'hui de thomas souliers bonjour
et à la une de l'actualité cette semaine
tensions au sommet entre le parti
socialiste et les verts après la
décision d'europe écologie de rejeter le
traité budgétaire européen
un clash de plus qui pose clairement la
question du maintien des deux ministres
écologistes au sein du gouvernement et
puis les députés au régime sec baisse de
10% de leurs indemnités gel du budget de
l'assemblée claude bartolone son
président veut faire de la chambre basse
une institution exemplaire dit il
il a dû justifier en même temps sur
l'embauché de son épouse plus de trois
millions de chômeurs en france 1 s'est
jamais franchi depuis 1999 un chiffre
qui tombe mal alors que le premier
budget du quinquennat va imposer aux
français des efforts de rigueur sans
précédent qui est avec nous pour
commenter cette semaine politique
chargée en actualité on l'a vu pour nous
le roux bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
ps de la première circonscription de
seine-saint-denis et président jeune
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée et ce depuis le mois de juin
alors votre défi c'est un petit peu un
remake du film mission impossible d'un
côté tous les députés de votre groupe
doivent parler du même bois et tous vos
alliés bien doit vous apporter leur
soutien un soutien sans faille au
gouvernement bon courage déjà et le
débat on va le voir autour du traité
budgétaire européen est bien en est le
parfait exemple mais avant cela ouvre de
l'euro on va regarder ce que pensent de
vous vos collègues députés on est allé à
l'assemblée des propos recueillis par
betty lachguer jérémy hartmann et chloé
bays dans les relations avec
l'opposition je le trouve peut-être un
peu sec un peu dur plus qu'il ne l'ait
humainement et normalement en tout cas
tel que je le pouvoir oeuvrer dans cette
scène je crois qu'on a bien choisissez
quelqu'un d'abord cas de l'expérience
était nécessaire si on n'a pas une
expérience pour
kim emmener un groupe dans ce contexte
on n'y arrive pas il est à la fois une
figure que je ne qualifierais pas de
tutélaire mais vraiment pas protectrice
et à dire qu'on est arrivé à l'assemblée
c'est un président groupe mais cet
ancien copain et il a su l'être avec
nous depuis des années avant même que
nous soyons députés à la limite quand on
l'entend s'exprimer quand on entend le
premier ministre on a presque
l'impression que c'est plus lui le
premier ministre que monsieur ayrault ça
c'est le problème du casting
gouvernemental et un caractère enjoué
je peux vous dire qu'il aime bien
plaisanter c'est un bon vivant et c'est
un quelqu'un qui est très conviviale en
même temps encore une fois s'il faut se
mettre en colère et se faire respecter
il sait faire et puis son principal
défaut c'est que là moi j'en ai marre
que sa prison du groupe on n'a plus le
temps de rien faire ensemble même pas
aller faire un petit tour à cergy
pontoise vous lui demanderez est ce que
ça veut dire il vous expliquera en
direct qu'est ce qui se passe est archi
forteresse de l'euro c'est quand j'avais
quelques week-ends un peu plus libre que
maintenant j'ai amené mes copains et
donc ce nouveau député volé un peu avec
moi le dimanche matin puis une de mes
passions c'est d'aller un peu d'avions
savez ces petits avions avec un petit
moteur à hélice et voilà à mais je
promets à mathieu de l'emmener bientôt à
nouveau sérieusement bruno le roux on a
entendu jean christophe lagarde qui dit
on a l'impression que c'est lui le
premier ministre ça vous flatte comment
ça se passe la répartition des rôles
entre vous et de 1,0 on essaye toujours
d'introduire bien avec jean-marc moi
j'ai je suis arrivé à l'assemblée
nationale en 1997 avec un président de
groupe qui à l'époque s'appelait jean
marc ayrault que j'ai désigné parce
qu'il me semblait être le meilleur
candidat et trois mois après d'ailleurs
quand on était revenu il ya déjà des
voix qui disait il faudrait peut-être
changé est ce qu'il va réussir
il a duré 15 ans président de groupe il
a été apprécié de tout le monde il a
mené ce qu'il fallait dans la majorité
comme dans l'opposition et moi je tiens
à être à mon rôle et mon rôle c'est de
soutenir le gouvernement d'organiser la
majorité pour que le gouvernement soit
soutenue à l'assemblée nationale en
faisant entendre la voix les socialistes
et moi j'ai 300 députés qui doivent se
sentir bien bien en soutenant
gouvernement est donc bien en existant
avec ce soutien au gouvernement
hier on a entendu un jean marc ayrault
il a dit qu'il était dans la
concertation c'est sa méthode il faut
quand même quelqu'un qui tranche c'est
vous non
le chef de l'état qui rend les
arbitrages moi je veux peser sur ces
abritera je veux lui dire quel est le
sentiment du groupe je veux faire en
sorte quand ils viennent à l'assemblée
nationale avec des textes il est tout le
temps une majorité la plus rassemblés
possible on va sûrement y venir mais
c'est le travail que j'ai amené en ce
moment par exemple sur le dossier
européen
alors justement on commence la semaine
avec le lundi et les écologistes devenu
indésirable au gouvernement alors que
plusieurs responsables socialistes sont
appelés les écologistes est la cohérence
matignon joue l'apaisement le départ du
gouvernement des ministres duflot et
qu'enfin ne se pose pas indiquent les
services du premier ministre soucieux de
ne pas envenimer les choses après le
rejet par europe ecologie les verts du
traité budgétaire européen
vous allez voir au sénat le traité
continue de diviser le groupe écologiste
c'est une enquête de s'embrasser
requerra le conseil national des verts
qui dit non au traité européen un clash
de plus avec leurs alliés du ps qui pour
la première fois pose clairement la
cohésion de la majorité voire du
maintien ou non des ministres verts au
gouvernement et si le vote du parti est
clair le positionnement de ses élus
l'est beaucoup moins
au sénat la moitié des douze sénateurs
europe ecologie les verts devraient
s'opposer au traité jean vincent placé
en tête mais il ne compte pas donner de
consigne de vote
de toute façon
ce traité est acquis très largement et
près de 80% des voix au ps
et je trouve ça tout à fait naturel
qu'il y a par exemple à l'assemblée
nationale une vingtaine de
parlementaires socialistes qui votre nom
moi ça me choque pas que certains votre
vote au oui chez les écologistes
à part les quatre ou cinq sénateurs
nonistes le reste du groupe plutôt
embarrassé devrait s'abstenir
on peut pas faire comme si nous n'étions
pas au gouvernement et donc il faut
assumer même s'il ya des choses
difficiles si les contraintes sont
fortes on doit aussi jouer la solidarité
et montrer qu'on n'est responsable
ils ne seraient que deux à voter oui on
ne sait pas bien être à l'aise dans la
manière d'être minoritaire dans la
majorité
pour moi il y a un contrat quand on est
dans le gouvernement
on vote le budget où on quitte
nous avons le devoir de nous respecter
ou alors de dire nous ne sommes pas
d'accord et nous sommes dans
l'opposition le ps appelle aujourd'hui
les verts à la cohérence et continue de
marteler que voter nous c'est affaiblir
françois hollande et donc le poids de la
france dans les négociations européennes
bruno comprends les arguments de jean
vincent placé vous l'aurez la majorité
sur ce traité européen en font c'est pas
grave s'ils ont quelques voix
écologistes pourquoi il faut absolument
mais ce n'est pas tout on ne fonde pas
son vote au prétexte que le texte serait
déjà majoritaire et si demain par
exemple la droite
l'opposition devait dire eh bien nous ne
voterons pas est-ce que cela suffirait à
changer le vote de monsieur place elle
est ce que l'on dit mais je prends le
cas de figure où il ne le voterai pas
est-ce que ce simple argument suffirait
à changer la position de monsieur place
et voilà on sait pas un débat on débat
c'est pas de bons arguments et donc les
verts j'ai été étonné par leur position
parce qu'en fin de compte elle m'a
semblé relever d'une logique très
partisane d'une logique de rapport de
force pas d'une logique de réfléchir à
ce qu est l enjeu européen pas d'une
logique de réfléchir à ce que la
cohérence quand on est dans la majorité
dont j'ai été étonné aller sous la ve ou
un peu déçu par la décision qu'ils ont
prise qui ne me semblait pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu est pourtant lors de
la campagne présidentielle il avait une
candidate europe ecologie les verts
c'était eva joly
et tous disaient on est contre ce traité
pourquoi il voterait aujourd'hui pour en
traiter
il disait avant on est contre on votera
contre le prévenu pendant la campagne
d'avant garde regardons si l'on va te
contre le traité c'est que l'on souhaite
qu'il soit repoussé
quelles seraient les conséquences si le
traité était repoussé aujourd'hui mais
même ceux qui votent non voulues 10 ce
serait quand même une perte de
considération considérable pour l'europe
nous retombent rayon dans une
instabilité que nous avons connu il ya
plusieurs mois la monnaie ce qui
attaquaient des pays qui sont des pays
comme la grèce le portugal et l'espagne
subirait de nouvelles attaques
il n'y aurait plus de mécanismes de
solidarité et tous ceux qui votent non
disent ah non on veut pas cela on veut
simplement marqué que dans cette période
en fin de compte le traité s'est pas
exactement ce que l'on pouvait vouloir
ce que je vous dise qu'ils ont toujours
dit les europe écologie déjà mais ils
l'ont dit quand nicolas sarkozy et son
constant mais ils l'ont dit quand
nicolas sarkozy et yttrium la république
moi je veux leur dire que le président a
changé il s'appelle françois hollande
aujourd'hui que le jour même de son
investiture le symel prenait l'avion
pour berlin avec quelques dangers
d'ailleurs et que il a entamé à côté de
ce traité il a ouvert des chantiers qui
n'avait pas été ouverts précédemment et
qui réoriente qui sont la base de ce
qu'il appelait la renégociation de ce
traité ce traité dans le texte n'a pas
été renégocié
mais ils y ont été ajoutés dépend qui
était dépend inconnu sous le bleu la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy jean
françois copé estime que françois
hollande paye là l'imposture de sa
campagne il avait dit qu'il renégocie
être le traité il n'y est pas parvenu je
me suis comme si c'était fait
quand on ajoute un volet croissance
quand on fait voter cette taxe
quand on décide de réorienter l'europe à
tel point que la banque centrale
européenne croit une décision qui était
inimaginable six mois auparavant
on peut prendre le mot que l'on veut
renégociation réorientation mais le
traité et le contexte européen n'est
plus le même aujourd'hui qu'il l'était
avec nicolas sarkozy et angela merkel on
va continuer sur ce sujet avec la
fameuse affaire du flou après un
week-end de cure de silence médiatique
et bien la ministre du logement s'est
enfin exprimé lundi soir france 2 cécile
duflot le clame haut et fort pas
question de quitter la table du conseil
des ministres
son credo la solidarité gouvernementale
qui vous est cher bruno le roux en
l'écoutant
donc je suis utile à mon travail de
ministre
utile à cette majorité est temps que le
travail que mène ce gouvernement le
gouvernement de jean marc ayrault et
pour notre pays alors ma place elle est
au sein de ce gouvernement vous demeurez
pas répondu sur votre position
personnelle
la position est ce que vous aimez parce
que ma position personnelle monsieur
pujadas
elle n'est pas intéressante pour la
bonne et simple raison qu'une ministre
n'a pas exprimé sa position personnelle
je rentre alors pourquoi ne dites-vous
pas je soutiens ce traité mais pas ce
que je vous dis que moi je suis une
ministre qui soutient les positions du
gouvernement donc vous me disiez soutien
traité sans me le dire
c'est très clair ça veut dire que je
soutient les positions qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement
une ratification qui a été décidé au
conseil des ministres mercredi dernier
ce sont des positions du gouvernement
tout en même temps que je suis une
écologiste et sur la place d'une
écologiste et d'être aujourd'hui au
gouvernement la réponse est oui et je
vous ai dit pourquoi nous a dit pourquoi
on avait du mal à comprendre on sent
entre les lignes qu'elle est opposée à
ce traité budgétaire européen et
pourtant elles n'osent pas le dire
qu'elle renie ses convictions ainsi lé
duflot non mais d'abord elle l'a dit il
ya plusieurs parties dans la majorité
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur tout
sinon nous serions dans le même parti et
pour autant il y as sur des sujets qui
sont des sujets structurants
une position qu'elle doit être une
position de l'ensemble du groupe
l'ensemble du gouvernement de l'ensemble
du groupe socialiste et j'irai même à
lire de l'ensemble de la majorité
et l'europe est un projet à structure
nous ne pouvons pas demain donné notre
confiance au président de la république
pour cette réorientation sans le lui
marqué est ce qu a dit cécile duflot
c'est très clair ministre elle était au
conseil des ministres qui ratifié et
elle a approuvé cette position
elle approuve donc ce qui est
aujourd'hui ce dispositif d'ensemble
créée par le président de la république
le texte le travail qu'il a menée au
niveau européen
le projet de loi de finances organique
qui va fixer la trajectoire pour nos
finances publiques
et c'est ce que je vais essayer de
traduire moi aussi dans quelques jours
avec la position du groupe socialiste et
je l'espère une position de la majorité
mais journal le monde dans un édito qui
réclamaient la démission de deux
ministres écologistes du gouvernement a
parlé des verts comme un groupuscule
irresponsable vous partagez cet avis non
mais oui enfin s'agissant du parti je
n'ai pas compris je pense qu'il ya une
irresponsabilité j'irais pas jusqu'a là
mais il ya une forme d'immaturité à
avoir fait de l'enjeu européen un enjeu
en fin de compte très partisan très
assemblée générale alors qu' il fallait
savoir dépasser il fallait savoir
prendre une position qui était cohérente
en suivant plus avec l'histoire des
verts
quand on voit que la décision qu'ils ont
prise est une position qui est en
rupture avec l'histoire qu'ils ont sur
l'europe mais avec les positions même de
leur groupe au parlement européen est
d'ailleurs lé député européen des verts
se sont insurgés contre cette décision
contraire à tout ce que les verts
avaient pu faire avec plus de dire au
niveau de la réorientation européenne et
donc je pense qu'il y avait une forme je
les dis d'immaturité je n'irai pas à
dire que c'est de l'irresponsabilité
mais en même temps je m'aperçois que
cécile duflot ee pascal canfin les deux
ministres eux sont dans la différence
ils sont écologistes et sont en même
temps dans la solidarité et qu'ils ont
trouvé un chemin qui est un chemin
intéressant et c'est dans ce contexte
que cécile duflot a présenté cette
semaine son projet de loi sur le
logement social le texte prévoit la
cession gratuite ou à bas prix du lait
du foncier public le relèvement du taux
obligatoire des logements sociaux à 25%
et la hausse des pénalités pour les
mairies qui ne le respectent pas les
amendes vont être multipliées par cinq
exemple en banlieue parisienne où sommes
allés à saint maur des fossés où le taux
de logements sociaux
atteint à peine les 7% reportage sur
place ivan rela et jérémy afane c'est
une grande ville aux allures de petit
village bucolique blotti dans une boucle
de la marne à saint-maur-des-fossés les
pavillon cossu sont nombreux les
logements sociaux beaucoup moins à peine
7%
l'une des plus mauvaise moyenne
nationale très loin des 25 % bientôt
imposée par le nouveau projet de loi
qu'importe les habitants sont
farouchement attachés à ce cadre de vie
préservé
tant pis si la commune s'exposent à de
lourdes pénalités financières
les gens vont payer pas avec je bois est
bon ils vont cueillir ses traits
pavillonnaire un sa mort alors puis a
pas de terrain c'est surtout ça je crois
moi je pense qu'il faut quand même une
certaine brassage de population mais il
faut pas que ça dépasse les vanités de
30% ses plus fins et plus vivable
on peut multiplier par 5 quand on est
socialiste facile ou par 10
mais ça règle pas c'est facile ça à
faire mais est-ce qu'on peut dégager des
terrains pour construire des logements
sociaux alors c'est ça le problème faut
abattre des pavillons une équation
insoluble à en croire les samariens une
loi toujours plus contraignante perçue
comme une provocation par le député
maire de la ville comme ce gouvernement
n'a pas d'argent qui n'a pas d'idées
qu'est-ce qui fait il fait de
l'affichage de l'idéologique ont
multiplié les amendes et on n'explique
pas au maire de sa mort mais comme aux
autres comment faire le foncier il faut
que j'achète puisque ma ville est
construite
ça représente au minimum vingt mille
euros par logement social henri plagnol
se dit des mini l'opposition municipale
parle plutôt de mauvaise foi politique
et tient à le prouver en nous présentant
un nouveau projet en construction en
plein centre ville ont veillé en fait il
a été vendu
monde qui est très fort a été vendu tout
de suite et puis il ya d'autres
programmes sur sa mort semble t'il donc
s'il n'y a pas des rites allemand de
construction de logements son appel
sociaux c'est peut-être ça relève d'une
non d'une absence de volonté politique
et ce alors là on se place dans un autre
domaine prête à se battre jusqu'au bout
le député maire pourrait prochainement
saisir le conseil constitutionnel pour
tenter de faire retoquer la loi alors
vous ne le regrettez vous répondez henri
plagnol
il est maire mais il ad'autres ans qu'il
dit ça coûte cher de construire des
logements sociaux aujourd'hui dans des
villes plutôt riche
quelle belle démonstration d'égoïsme
quand même parce que tant des villes
plutôt riche
on devrait donc faire en sorte de
n'avoir rien à afficher en matière de
solidarité tout laisser aux autres
villes faire en sorte que les files
continue à s'allonger dans les mairies
sur la demande à être bien logé à
pouvoir faire évoluer sa famille au fil
de sa composition
donc ce reportage est la démonstration
de l'égoïsme qui a conduit à ce que nous
fassions sans attendre cette nouvelle
loi pour d'abord mettre des terrains à
disposition des maires qui disent vas
nous n'en avons pas là on voit bien dans
le cas de figure il y en a il y en a
pour faire du logement qui n'est pas du
logement social mais il y a des communes
qui ont des problèmes de foncier pour
attirer du foncier donc cette loi vise à
permettre d'acquérir des terrains de
mettre à disposition des terrains et en
même temps de dire aux villes vous
n'avez plus d' excuse
nous ne vous demandons pas de faire plus
de logements sociaux que vous n'avez
aujourd'hui d'autres logements mais nous
demandent de vous demandons de prendre
votre part à un objectif national qui
doit être d'abord la construction de
logements sociaux et ensuite faire en
sorte que nos habitants nos concitoyens
soient bien logés qui préfèrent payer
des pénalités et qui vont peut-être même
faire peser ces nouvelles pénalités sur
les contribuables en augmentant les
impôts locaux qu'est ce que vous
répondez je les laisserai à leurs
responsabilités la loi peut leur
permettre ça puisque nous avons encore
des pénalités et pas une obligation ça
va coûter de plus en plus cher et en
même temps je crois que c'est un
affichage qui est mauvais pour la
cohésion nationale quand une commune
décide de pointé du doigt en fin de
compte ce qui viendrait à tenter demain
à quoi à sa qualité de vie à la relation
entre ses habitants
non je crois que le logement social et
la mixité sociale est aujourd'hui une
richesse et les véritables problèmes que
l'on peut voir c'est dans les endroits
où une
à plus de mixité parce qu'il n'y a que
du logement social et que nous
n'arrivons plus à faire en sorte qu'il y
ait cette mixité entre les gens qui
viennent travailler les gens qui ont des
niveaux de revenus différents et là je
crois qu'il ya une réflexion qui
s'impose à tous les maires l inverse
de ce cas là bruno le roux lui vit dans
un département de telus d'un département
où il ya un fort taux de logements
sociaux entre 30 50 % selon les études
benoist apparu l'ancien ministre du
logement propose une loi sru miroir on
pas rentrer dans les détails mais en
gros c'est que les communes qui aurait
pour lui aurait pour obligation de
construire d'autres types de logements
quand le taux de logements sociaux est
supérieur à 35 % notamment la
construction de logements intermédiaires
à ce cas pas en risque dans certaines
villes notamment seine-saint-denis qui
est trop de logements sociaux et c'est
ce qu'elles font n'y a jamais trop de
logements sociaux et pour autant la
question c'est d'assurer la mixité mais
on le voit bien salé saint denis le taux
de logements sociaux n'est pas supérieur
à 50% ça veut dire qu'il y à beaucoup
d'autres logements se dire que nous
sommes un département qui a sion
véritablement nous assurons en
seine-saint-denis la mixité sociale et
avec quelques fois parce que il y a eu
des endroits où cela il ya pu y avoir
une concentration de logements sociaux
des problèmes qu'il faut le régler en
matière d'accessibilité en transport en
matière simplement de situations
sociales qui peuvent être difficile donc
de moyens pour l'école tout ce que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui et qui fait qu'il y
a des quartiers qui peuvent être en
grande en grande difficulté mais nous
nous sommes aujourd'hui fiers de la
population qui est la nôtre parce
qu'elle représente cette mixité et je
crois que nous on devrait regarder ce
qui se fait en seine-saint-denis
attentivement mardi claude bartolone
veut une assemblée nationale exemplaire
et c'est ce qu'on appelle un vieux
serpent de mer la réduction du train de
vie des élus
le sujet revient depuis des années et
bien des paroles aux actes claude
bartolone a proposé mardi une réforme
notamment des indemnités des députés
toutes les précisions
avec jean-baptiste daoulas il était très
attendu sur le thème de l'exemplarité
claude bartolone est arrivé avec une
longue liste d'annonce économies
budgétaires entraînent la cour des
comptes à l'assemblée réductions liées
rfm équité transparence sur la réserve
parlementaire
je peux le dire jamais une réforme de
telle ampleur n'a été menée à
l'assemblée nationale pour donner
l'exemple en temps de crise l'indemnité
pour frais de mandat des députés
baissera de 10 % soit environ
640 euros en moins tous les mois les
sommes économisées seront destinés à
améliorer la situation des assistants
parlementaires le futur déontologue de
l'assemblée devra proposer un nouveau
forfait pour indemniser les députés des
mesures qui divise l'opposition
je suis quelque chose qui est naturel
qui s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans la volonté
de maîtrise des coûts que j'ai développé
pendant cinq ans et de transparence il
est pas normal que les français puissent
penser en période de crise que les
parlementaires ne font pas un effort et
j'approuve à 100 % et et des deux mains
cette disposition ses propositions
démagogiques qui vise toujours à vouloir
diminuer pour donner des signes ou
flatter une catégorie de l'opinion je
pense que ça n'est pas bon si un bon
signe pour la démocratie
claude bartolone défend les prérogatives
de l'assemblée son nouveau cheval de
bataille la lutte contre la
prolifération des agences haute autorité
et autres commissions il existe dans nos
pays un empilement impressionnant de
comités théodule
on en dénombre 680 claude bartolone
souhaitent que leur mission de contrôle
et de prospective reviennent dans le
giron de l'assemblée sur l'application
des lois le président de l'assemblée
nationale annonce d'ores et déjà trois
rapports sur les emplois d'avenir sur
les recrutements à l'éducation nationale
et sur les contrats de génération
alors on le voit vous ne leur ou des
mesures sont désormais sur la table
certains pensent que claude bartolone
n'est pas allé assez loin notamment sur
la rfm il y aura simplement une
déclaration sur l'honneur pour vérifier
tout cela est ce que vous aurait
souhaité qu'il aille un peu plus loin
sur ce projet vous doutez une
déclaration sur l'honneur soit quelque
chose qui ne suffisent pas quand un
député dit aujourd'hui pour remplir mon
mandat j'utilise mes frais fonction de
ce qu'ils mettent autorisé qu'il
renouvelle chaque année cette
déclaration sur l'honneur et que vous le
savez un déontologue va être recruté
enfin l'assemblée puisque le poste est
créé et qu'il va avoir un même de
regarder cela moi je souhaite même qu'il
puisse faire un contrôle aléatoire pour
les députés est formulée ensuite des
recommandations générales pour revoir
pour qu'ils constatent et pour que ce
qu'ils constatent qu'ils puissent le
faire savoir pour procéder à des
améliorations
parce qu'il peut y avoir même des
interrogations en sorte qu'ils rentrent
ou qui ne rentre pas
dans ce forfait mais j'observe qu'alors
que nous ne sommes pas encore en session
ordinaire depuis notre élection il y a
déjà une réforme qui a été mise en place
et les propositions de claude bartolone
interviennent dès le début d'un mandat
c'est à dire que là où on se dit souvent
il faudrait faire il faudrait et où la
majorité précédente nous dit après avoir
été battu à vous ne faites pas cela vous
auriez dû alors que pendant dix ans les
choses n'ont pas véritablement nationale
propose de payer des impôts sur l'irfm
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ça de
fiscaliser cette indemnité non je ne
pense pas parce que c'est une indemnité
qui doit servir aux frais de mandat si
elle n'est pas totalement utilisé à mon
sens elle doit être reversée à
l'assemblée nationale elle ne peut pas
être un complément de salaire elle doit
être utilisée pour le mandat qui est le
nôtre et uniquement le manta qui est le
nôtre nombre de leurs au hasard du
calendrier ou pas le même jour on
l'apprenait que claude bartolone avait
embauché son épouse elle en charge
notamment des droits des femmes
vous avez réagi sur public sénat ce
n'est pas anodin mais pas une erreur on
sent quand même votre agacement sur ce
point là parce qu'il y avait là une
concordance des choses mais véronique
elle aurait dû travailler avec claude
bartolone
depuis qu'il a été élu à l'assemblée
nationale elle travaillait avec lui
auparavant au conseil général elle
travaillait avec le ministère de la
ville c'est là qu'ils se sont rencontrés
est la paire métier elle a des
compétences et elle les a toujours
exercé sur le terrain qui était celui
des cabinets de la politique
la relation est donc il était tout à
fait normal qu'elle soit là où elle est
aujourd'hui
ensuite il y a eu une concordance ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs peut-être pas
totalement voilà c'est peut-être pas
totalement venu par hasard le droit de
vote des étrangers aux élections locales
n'en finit plus d'agiter la majorité
présidentielle un groupe de 75 députés
socialistes demandent la mise en oeuvre
sans plus tarder de cette promesse de
campagne quand françois rebsamen le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
ne serait pas choqué que l'on attende un
peu pour la mettre en oeuvre en
l'écoutent
si cela permet de démontrer qu'il n'y a
aucune volonté manipulatrice délectera
derrière cela eh bien pourquoi pas
sorti des municipales je suis pour le
droit de vote puisque je les voter j'ai
porté des étrangers aux élections
locales
cette proposition que nicolas sarkozy
avait reprise par trois fois qui faisait
rassemblement un moment nous devons
convaincre c'est une belle formule du
premier ministre des esprits éclairés et
il y en a au centre et à droite que
c'est pas une mesure électoraliste
c'est un engagement un nouveau droit
c'est un nouveau drone qu elle peut
attendre la fin du quinquennat c'est
très important vous dites on peut
laisser passer les prochains celui-ci
si ça peut aider des esprits éclairés
alors déjà envoyé qu'il ya aucune
manipulation électorale derrière
pourquoi pas on a l'impression que la
gauche n'arrivera jamais à faire voter
ce texte était déjà une promesse de
campagne de françois mitterrand en 1981
ça fait partie des sans engagement nous
sommes totalement pour à gauche et je le
dis ici je ne laisserai pas inscrire
cette proposition à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée
si elle a des chances d'être battus et
donc le travail à faire il est clair il
est de faire en sorte de dégager une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat et une majorité donc des trois
cinquièmes pour modifier notre
constitution
saleh n'ont pas encore attendre il
n'attend pas il faut faire le travail
tout de suite mais en même temps avant
2014 est sûr j'espère qu'il faudrait le
faire le plus vite possible
c est notre travail doit être un travail
mais attendez moi je sais combien je
compte deux députés dans ma majorité lui
le sait et donc nous savons qu'il nous
manque aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
députés
il faut faire le travail de conviction
moi je souhaite et l'appel je les dis
l'appel des députés aurait été un appel
très utile s'il y avait eu là dedans la
moitié de députés qui ne viennent pas du
parti socialiste et de la gauche parce
que cela aurait représenté un mouvement
mais je vais même plus loin je veux
trouver une majorité au parlement et en
même temps je veux convaincre les
français parce que c'est une proposition
qui doit être fait et y retourner sur la
question oui j'observe que l'opinion
publique s'est retournée moi je veux
continuer à expliquer aux français
pourquoi cette décision est une bonne
décision pourquoi cette loi est une loi
de cohésion locale une loi qui permet de
mettre tous ensemble ceux qui font vivre
aujourd'hui nos villes sans rien céder
sur la question la citoyenne que les
sans rien c'est pas le moment il avait
donc même si visiblement il a un peu
changé d'avis non quand il dit c'est pas
le moment
il sait qu'il constate qu'il n'y a pas
de majorité et moi je le redis ici de
façon très claire je ne veux pas que ce
texte soit inscrit pour que nous nous
donnions bonne conscience en disant
c'était une proposition nous l'avons
proposé à l'assemblée nationale et nous
n'avons pas été capables de la faire
voter au parlement
je veux au moment où elle sera inscrite
que nous sachions le chemin qui nous
conduit à son adoption
merci on passe tout de suite à la
journée de mercredi sont désormais trois
millions trois millions de chômeurs en
france et cela faisait treize ans que le
nombre de chômeurs n'avait pas dépasser
la barre fatidique 3 millions 11 me
personnes sans emploi en france le
gouvernement doit faire face un seizième
mois de hausse consécutive les
explications de rim et d'amr les
chiffres de l'emploi au plus bas depuis
13 ans le nombre de chômeurs a augmenté
de 0,8 pour cent en un mois soit plus de
3 millions de personnes
face à ces mauvais chiffres le
gouvernement maintient sa promesse d'
inverser la courbe du chômage d'ici à
fin 2013
ces moyens cent cinquante mille emplois
d'avenir 500000 contrat de génération
ainsi que 2000 nouveaux cdi à pôle
emploi des réformes inefficace pour la
droite appelle vraiment le gouvernement
à prendre en compte la situation à
sortir des mesurettes et des pansements
pour avoir dans le budget 2013 des
mesures puissante pour recréer ce choc
de confiance qui a key le préalable à la
croissance elle-même préalable à la
baisse du chômage
et c'est bien le problème la croissance
sans cesse revues à la baisse à peine
0,8 pour cent prévue en 2013
dans ce contexte de crise les
économistes ne voient pas comment sortir
de l'impasse
on voit que la difficulté justement avec
le budget pour 2013 c'est qu'on va être
dans un plan d'austérité massif de
l'ordre de 37 milliards d'euros qui va
peser sur le revenu des ménages sur leur
pouvoir d'achat et sur leur consommation
qui a pesé aussi sur le revenu des
entreprises à travers notamment l'impôt
société et donc sur leur investissement
et donc dans ce scénario là on aura des
destructions d'emplois et ce pessimisme
est partagé par une majorité de français
selon un récent sondage huit personnes
sur dix ne croit parc à une baisse du
chômage 10 jan
les français n'y croient pas est ce que
le fait d' inverser la courbe du chemin
d'ici un an c'est un objectif tenable
oui
oui oui en tout cas c'est l'objectif que
nous a fixé le président de la
république et il faut que les français
soient convaincus que nous allons tout
mettre en oeuvre il ya une situation de
crise il ya une situation économique
elle s'impose bien souvent la question
c'est de savoir si on regarde cette
crise ou si l'on essaye de l'inversé et
ce qui a été fait et les chiffres du
chômage nous savions en gagnant
l'élection présidentielle est d'ailleurs
dans la campagne nous avions dit que
pendant plusieurs mois les chiffres du
chômage allait malheureusement se
dégrader parce que les prévisions de
crise était forte et en même temps parce
que nous savions que rien n'avait été
mis en place pour essayer de contrer
cela et là dans les trois mois qui vont
venir nous aurons déployer tout
l'arsenal des moyens publics pour faire
en sorte d' agir contre le chômage c'est
à dire que jamais un gouvernement et un
parlement 500 les emplois d'avenir la
droite parle de mesurette
est-ce que les ans près d'amiens soins
la mesure j'entends bien faire des lans
j'ai entendu mesurettes et pansements
mais avez vous le souvenir avez vous le
souvenir d'un seul dispositif qui était
épris durant ces trois dernières années
face à la crise en matière d'emploi par
le précédent logement gouvernement pas
un seul
vous n'en trouverez pas un seul et donc
quand on parle de mesurettes et de
pansements j'aurais préféré qu'ils en
prennent quelques uns mais en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas il y à
eut d'abord la financement des contrats
aidés les emplois d'avenir la
négociation aujourd'hui sur les contrats
de génération la négociation qui
aboutira au parlement sur ce qu'on
appelle la sécurité de l'emploi et
l'adaptation des entreprises en période
de crise la banque publique
d'investissement le plan compétitivité
des pme qui est dévoilée dans le budget
et qui va se mettre en place dans les
prochaines semaines c'est à dire un
dispositif où il n'y a pas moins de six
à sept dimensions qui ont été prises dès
les six premiers mois pour inverser la
courbe vous portez la responsabilité du
gouvernement précédent françois hollande
l'a déjà fait de new york quand il était
à l'onu alors ces arguments la faute à
la droite quand la droite dit c'est la
faute à la gauche on tourne un petit peu
en tourne pas en rond mais moi je ne
veux pas revenir pendant des mois
j'observe quand même qu'il y a 6 mois
quand nous étions dans l'hémicycle dans
l'opposition aux questions d'actualité
françois fillon faisait toujours
référence à lionel jospin et à
l'héritage dix ans plus tard mais moi je
dis simplement que nous sommes là moins
de six mois après qu'il ya une inertie
en politique et que l'élection
présidentielle la seule chose qu'elle
est remis à zéro
c'est le conteur démocratique un nouveau
président de la république
nouvelle majorité pour le reste le
lendemain de notre victoire
il y avait toujours 3 millions de
chômeurs et 3 millions de chômeurs qui a
été un chiffre en augmentation
il y avait toujours 1500 milliards de
dette dans le pays il y avait toujours
une croissance totalement anémiée et
sans qu'il soit rien fait pour essayer
de la booster un peu il y avait toujours
un déficit public qui dépassait les 5 %
et cela ça n'a pas été remis à zéro par
l'élection présidentielle et nous sommes
aujourd'hui obligés de faire avec une
situation qui la plus catastrophique que
notre pays n'ait jamais connue françois
fillon jean françois copé les deux
candidats à la présidence de l'ump ont
dévoilé mercredi leur programme mais une
petite phrase du second a occulté la
présentation de ces programmes dans un
livre à paraître jean françois copé
entend briser un tabou en employant
l'expression raciste anti-blanc une
expression jusque là utilisée par le
front national germes andrieu
officiellement la campagne n'a pas
encore commencé pourtant le duel entre
françois fillon et jean françois copé
s'accélère chaque candidat affiche
clairement sa stratégie dès vendredi
un livre programme pour jean françois
copé un manifeste pour une droite
décomplexée une campagne sans tabou sur
la sécurité le travail l'immigration
avec la dénonciation d'un racisme anti
blanc pour autant pas question de
confondre l'ump et le front national
nous nous sommes toujours opposés et
nous nous opposerons toujours à une
alliance électorale avec le front
national
mais pour autant et je le dis avec la
même force cela ne nous empêchera pas de
traiter les sujets qui engagent qui
concerne qui indigne qui exaspère qui
inquiète les françaises et les français
du côté de françois fillon c'est aussi
l'heure du projet mais en contre-pied
par rapport à jean françois copé
l'ancien premier ministre propose avant
tout le rassemblement et le redressement
de la france face à la crise je récuse
tout les débats sur la droitisation oula
centre centralisation de l'ump ça n'est
pas en penchant d'un côté ou de l'autre
que nous pourrons proposer aux français
un vrai projet de redressement national
qu'ils seront en mesure d'accepter
en attendant le duel ne fait que
commencer la campagne officielle aura
lieu du 5 octobre au 17 novembre
et seuls les militants pourront les
départager le 18
alors jean françois copé entend briser
un tabou avec cette expression au
racisme anti blanc ce que c'est un
prélude à des accords avec le front
national ce sport je l'espère pas mais
en même temps vous avez bien ramener
dans ce reportage cette petite phrase à
ce qu'elle est une escarmouche
supplémentaire de graff d'ailleurs je
pense en matière de dérives linguistique
politique mais une escarmouche dans la
guerre des chefs aujourd'hui à l'ump où
l'on pense que les militants vont être
sensible à ce qui va être encore plus à
droite encore plus en opposition encore
plus en passerelles avec le front
national puisqu'il ya une partie de la
droite qui aujourd'hui inquiète de ce
qui se passait il ya des porosités qui
existe aujourd'hui
donc je crois que c'est dangereux moi je
les dis dans lé racisme mais je ne
cherche pas à faire de distinction est
partout il s'exprime sous quelque forme
qu'il s'exprime
je combats le racisme par celui qui le
profèrent je condamne tous les propos
d'où qu'ils viennent en matière de race
est un comprimé sur le fond est ce qu'il
existe aujourd'hui un racisme anti blanc
mais je ne veux pas rentrer dans ce
débat il peut y avoir des manifestations
telles que celles ci d'abord ce n'est
pas quelque chose que j'observe de façon
généralisée
et d'ailleurs si je l'observais mais non
mais si je l'observais de façon
généralisée quelle en serait la solution
je veux bien qu'on soit dans la
dénonciation de propos qui avaient déjà
été tenues auparavant et dont on voit
bien je le redis pourquoi ils ont été
tenus mais moi je ne différencie pas les
racismes et s'il y avait un moment donné
devant moi l'expression d'un racisme
anti blanc je le condamnerais de la même
façon que je condamne tous les autres
racisme et donc je ne suis pas là pour
chercher des segmentations parce que
d'hommes
est ce que monsieur copé nous
expliquerait que ce racisme là serait
plus grave qu'un autre racisme parce que
nous serions ici en france parce que
nous serions dans notre république et
donc c'est une un quelque chose qui nous
amène sur un fort mauvais débat que la
façon dont il pose les choses
moi je le sais que manquent pas je ne
différencie pas les racismes après
mercredi la journée de jeudi et arnaud
montebourg qui dès soir les salariés de
florange
en visite hier le ministre du
redressement productif a promis un bras
de fer avec arcelormittal
les salariés ont montré leur colère hier
à florange
les deux hauts fourneaux qui sont
enfermés depuis plus d'un an et bien on
ne sait toujours pas s'ils seront fermés
définitivement à priori oui dit arnaud
montebourg les explications de rim
benameur visite agitée pour arnaud
montebourg à florange très attendue par
les syndicats le ministre du
redressement productif est venu
présenter le plan de sauvetage du
gouvernement pour les hauts fourneaux
lorrains après un mois de négociations
difficiles
je ne suis pas venu faire des promesses
car c'est un bras de fer difficile qui
sans galles avec une multinationale de
l'acier
ce que nous souhaitons c'est arcelor
mittal comprennent le gouvernement
français à l'exercie tout son poids est
dit-il solution de repli qui surcroît il
ya des investissements dans la partie il
continuera à exploiter un investissement
de 150 millions d'euros pour entretenir
les fourneaux et c'est justement une
partie de ses hauts fourneaux que l'état
aimerait récupérer pour un euro
symbolique
ensuite il se chargerait de trouver un
repreneur capable de faire revivre le
site
mais avant il faut légiférer la loi est
déjà prête mais doit encore être votée
peu de temps avant françois hollande
recevait discrètement lakshmi mittal à
l'elysée il avait fait du sauvetage de
florange l'une de ses promesses de
campagne
cette promesse les 3000 salariés au
chômage technique depuis 14 mois ne
l'oublient pas la direction
d'arcelormittal devrait-elle annoncé sa
décision
lundi c'est un bras de fer qui s'engage
avec arcelormittal a dit arnaud
montebourg ce cap a quand même un
sentiment d'impuissance quand on est
devant toutes ces usines qui ferment
d'abord oui vous avez raison de le dire
nous avons découvert beaucoup elles deux
plans sociaux et beaucoup de dossiers
tels que ceux ci qu'ils n'avaient pas
été traitées autrement de par les
paroles auparavant et c'est vrai que
quand l'état n'est pas au capital et
l'état n'est pas au capital aujourd'hui
il ya nécessité à trouver des leviers la
nécessité d'avoir des discussions bien
en avant ces discussions n'ont pas
existé en tout cas n'ont pas existé pour
protéger l'emploi pour protéger les
sites et il n'y avait eu que des
déclarations est donc aujourd'hui nous
allons essayer de parce que moi je
comprends surtout dans un bassin qui est
en situation difficile son emploi
sinistrés on pourrait même le dire sur
l'emploi je comprends cette colère qui
peuvent s'exprimer à dire mais fait
quelque chose oui nous allons faire j'ai
déposé
je dépose en ce moment une proposition
de loi à l'assemblée nationale sur
l'obligation de reprise de site qui sont
rentables
on le voit aujourd'hui il ya une
négociation menée par le gouvernement
j'ai été heureux que le président de la
république le premier ministre hier de
dire fort sur france 2 10 qu'il
souhaitait qu'elle soit inscrite le plus
vite possible à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée
vous êtes un agenda non je partage en a
maintenant son ministre du des relations
avec le parlement mais quand le premier
ministre dit rapidement s'est rapidement
à la proposition de loi qui a déjà été
voté par le sénat une proposition de loi
communiste sur l'interdiction des
licenciements boursiers là aussi on va
avoir un calendrier ce que ça va revenir
au parlement
mais là encore le premier ministre l'a
dit hier ça fait partie des textes qui
sont des textes d'abord qu'il faut ce
qu'on appelle sécuriser juridiquement
parce que il y à des obstacles des
obstacles notamment constitutionnel et
moi je ne veux pas ici faire des fed
annonce à dire que nous déposerons lyon
que nous voterions des textes qui
derrière seraient des textes dont nous
savons qu'ils présenteraient des
difficultés qu'il ne serait pas
applicable ce que nous voulons c'est
fournir des outils supplémentaires à la
négociation avec des grands groupes tels
que ceux ci quand ils veulent à un
moment donné faire une fermeture d'usiné
qui est dû pour des raisons de
rentabilité qui est dû pour des raisons
qui sont étrangères aux sites alors que
celui ci pourrait et devrait continuer
et donc j'accompagne cette volonté du
gouvernement de traiter ce dossier par
de nouveaux investissements part
éventuellement le plus rapidement
possible la le fait de trouver un
nouveau repreneur et j'espère pouvoir y
contribuer les ici en faisant voter très
très vite cette proposition de loi qui a
été élaboré par moi-même et françois
brottes
à la veille de la présentation en
conseil des ministres du budget 2013
jean marc ayrault a passé hier son grand
oral en prime time sur france 2 et il a
promis que les classes moyennes ne
seraient pas concernées par de nouvelles
hausses d'impôts en écoute un revenu
constant
neuf français sur dix neuf contribuer
français sur dix se seront pas concernés
par les augmentations de fiscalité
d'après les chiffres qu'on a là vous me
your les deux ça ce qui est déjà été je
parle des mesures qui vont être mises
dans le budget 2010 et mesure là auront
un impact sur 2000 que oui mais je suis
prêt à me l'expliquer mais les mesures
nouvelles parce que on a tellement écrit
que les mesures nouvelles à la matraque
et tout le monde
ces mesures nouvelles épargne les
classes moyennes et les classes
populaires est-ce que vous pensez que le
premier ça rassurait les classes
moyennes c'est quand même une rigueur de
gauche mais qui ne dit pas son nom c'est
du sérieux
c'est un budget qui est un budget
sérieux et au moment où il y à la crise
ce n'est plus le temps de laisser filer
les déficits de notre pays c'est
toujours les mêmes qui payent d'ailleurs
quand il a des déficits qu'on laisse
filer
c'est toujours les mêmes à qui on
demande des efforts et bien nous allons
fait un budget qui est un budget sérieux
avec trois tiers 10 milliards de
dépenses
supprimés sur le budget de l'état donc
des économies sur le budget de l'état et
10 milliards prélevés sur les
entreprises en matière de fiscalité sur
les ménages et sur les ménages oui je le
dis ici nous épargnons totalement les
gens qui sont les plus modestes les
foyers modestes et noter les classes
moyennes parce que tout simplement c'est
eux qui avaient été mis à contribution
durant dix ans c'est à eux qu'on a fait
payer tous les privilèges et donc ceux
qui étaient les plus privilégiés je les
dis déjà depuis plusieurs mois vont
devoir se réhabituer dans quelques
semaines à aller dans la boîte aux
lettres pour y trouver une feuille
d'impôts il avait oublié de faire ce
geste qu'ils vont revenir à quelque
chose qui va être un comportement normal
en matière d'impôts et on va rentrer
dans le détail de ce budget 2013 30
milliards d'impôts d'euros d'impôts et
d'économie vous le disiez pour ramener
le déficit à 3% fin 2013
toutes les explications un des visas
berthelot mes parents l'effort sera
partagé entre hausse des prélèvements et
réduction des dépenses principaux
touchés par les augmentations d'impôts
les ménages les plus aisés et les
grandes entreprises taxe à 75%
rétablissement du barème de liesse f
plafonnement des niches fiscales impôt
sur les sociétés le gouvernement espère
dégager 20 milliards d'euros
tous les ministères seront concernés
sauf l'éducation la justice et
l'intérieur 2000 suppressions de poste à
bercy
7000 au ministère de la défense
diminution de 3,6 pour cent des crédits
de la culture de 7 3% pour l'agriculture
gel des salaires des fonctionnaires
au total 10 milliards d'impôts doivent
être trouvées l'état est donc appelés à
se serrer la ceinture
une cure de rigueur historique pour un
premier budget le gouvernement espère
qu'avec ces mesures il pourra tenir son
objectif de ramener le déficit public à
3% du pib reste une grande incertitude
la croissance prévue à 0,8 pour cent un
chiffre qui laisse les économistes
sceptiques
alors ce budget est donc table sur une
prévision de croissance de 0,8 pour cent
pourtant ces prévisions sont jugées un
peu trop optimiste est ce que le
gouvernement ne va pas être obligé de
procéder très rapidement à des
ajustements avec un projet de loi de
finances rectificative il faut toujours
parce que nous espérons avec les mesures
prises dans ce budget essayer de faire
en sorte de 2
d'apporter un surplus de dynamisme
surplus de croissance par la justice des
propositions que nous faisons est donc
aujourd'hui les prévisions des
économistes tourne autour de 0,5 pour
cent de croissance à peu près nous avons
fait un choix à 0,8 qui montre le
volontarisme que nous voulons et que ce
que nous souhaitons à la fin de l'année
2013 pour ce budget donc c'est un choix
volontariste et nous pensons ce
différentiel entre les propositions des
économistes aujourd'hui qu'ils se
trompent aussi quelquefois et celles qui
sont les nôtres et nous assumons
pleinement
eh bien ça va être justement la
différence due à notre politique la
différence due au dynamisme
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas mais en même
temps il y a toujours eu des budgets
rectificatifs et donc je ne peux pas
vous dire qu'il n'y en aura pas mais
quand nous faisons par exemple sur la
fiscalité des entreprises
le pari d'épargner les pme et même
d'aider les pme qu'est ce qu'il y aura
un plan compétitivité des pme qui va
être en rajouter à cela dans les
prochaines semaines c'est parce que nous
pensons qu'elles vont être ceux elles
vont permettre ce différentiel que nous
voulons leur adresser à elle que nous
voulons leur donner un signe de
confiance en leur vivant dans une
période difficile
vous allez avoir accès plus facilement
crédit vous allez avoir à sec plus
facilement financement de vos
investissements
vous allez pouvoir embaucher de façon
peut-être que se vouent plus flexible
par rapport à ce que vous nous demandiez
et donc participer participer dans ce
moment de crise à ce qu'est l'effort
national en embauchant et en essayant
d'aller de l'avant des chiffres on voit
les prévisions de croissance mais aussi
ses 3 % est ce que c'est un objectif
tenable claude bartolone émettait des
doutes à ce sujet elisabeth guigou aussi
mais il faut le tenir
c'est un objectif qui est un objectif
qui rend crédible aujourd'hui notre
politique de désendettement
les français comprennent bien ce nom
peut pas continuer sur l'endettement qui
a été accumulée dans notre pays
et si demain il doit y avoir des
corrections de ce chiffre
elles viendront d'une croissance
européenne qui aura été plus faible que
ce nous que ce que nous prévoyons et
donc c'est la commission européenne qui
nous dira ah ben là il y à une marche
que permet d'ailleurs le traité parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que le traité que nous allons voter dans
quelques jours nous permet ces
corrections sur le retour à l'équilibré
en matière de finances publiques car si
vous ne leur ont d'avoir été
invitée merci fine l'invité de parlement
hebdo
la semaine prochaine vous retrouverez
comme d'habitude aux moracchini et
mickaël szames s à bientôt et très bon
week-end sur les chaînes parlementaires